Before we go into how
virtual memory works,
let's first see why do we even
want to have virtual memory?
And the short answer is that we
want to have virtual memory because
the programmer and the hardware have
different views of what memory means.
In the hardware view,
the machine has some memory modules
with an actual amount of memory that
can be accessed by the real processor.
Let's say that this
module is 2 gigabytes and
this module is 2 gigabytes.
So what the hardware really has
is 4 gigabytes of memory, and
the address is for this 4 gigabytes
are going to be 0 through 4 gigabytes.
In contrast, the programmer's view of
memory is that it's a huge array with
address that go from 0 to a very, very
large number if it's a 64 bit machine.
This is many, many gigabytes.
Obviously, this is much more than
with the machine really has.
Some of this memory might
be reserved for the system.
Some of this memory contains
the actual program instructions.
Some of it is for static data.
Then we have the memory for
the heap, which is where malloc finds
its memory, and this heap can grow.
And then some of it, usually very
high in the memory address space,
is the stack.
And that typically grows this way.
But the programmer doesn't
really want to be bothered
by how much space is there
between the heap and the stack.
What they want to do is simply malloc,
or push things on the stack, and
they never run out of memory.
And in a 64 bit of rest space,
chances are they won't
actually run out of memory.
But the problem is the actual amount of
memory that they're using might be less,
or it might be much more than the actual
memory that the machine has here.
Things are actually
much more complicated
because we typically don't run
only run one program on a machine,
we actually simultaneously
having multiple programs run.
You might be having something
that browses files here,
an MP3 player playing in the background,
and a word processor here.
Each of these sees the address
space that begins at 0 and
ends at the very large address.
We don't want to write our programs so
that this needs to run as
the first program in the system.
This needs to run as the second
program in the system.
You want to write the program as if it
was the only program in the system and
then just run multiple
programs like that.
But that means that this
program's idea of memory is
it thinks it has all of this memory.
This program similarly thinks
it has all of this memory.
So as far as these two programs
are concerned, for example,
their code might well be at the same
address in each program, although
in fact they each have different
instructions at those addresses.
So virtual memory is a way of
reconciling how the programmers view
memory and how the hardware actually
needs to view memory in order to work.